this moment was tragically predictable
alexei navalny back on russian soil for
the first time since he was poisoned
with a novichok nerve agent and flown to
berlin in a coma
arrested at border control a final kiss
for his wife julia
before he follows the police away
moments earlier he told journalists how
happy he was to be back
but that does not mean that he won't be
jailed for them
a way for the kremlin to put out of
sight the man they refused to name
who they tried to dismiss as an
irrelevance
is that why his plane was diverted at
the last moment
after an afternoon of semi-chaos at
moscow's vanukova airport
rammed with supporters and with members
of the non-kremlin press
with riot police drafted in to keep
order
there was just a cheer and then uh
expletive that i won't repeat on air
about president putin
when it was announced that the plane had
landed at ceramic
it's been diverted from blue cover
presumably because of these large crowds
that the riot police have not
been managing to control and there have
been numerous arrests
it was exceptionally brave to come home
but navalny had always said that he
would
and arrests and long periods in
detention and nothing new for him
but now he knows how close he was to
being killed
an assassination attempt that he blames
on vladimir putin directly
his wife julia has put up with so much
over the years
and so it continues
russia will be free the crowds chanted
today as supporters were dragged away by
police
it is what navalny is fighting for but
it is a long way off
diana magnay sky news moscow